Prendí la computadora, empecé a googlear y estaba listo para escribir las noticias.
Y recibí una llamada de mi mamá que era normal para ella ya que le gusta
enviar textos, mails, hacer llamadas, Facebook, Instagram, todas esas cosas.
Contesté la llamada pensando que hablaría de chismes de la iglesia,
o para contarme sobre WorldStarHipHop que acababa de descubrir.
Pero, al contestar el teléfono,
mi mamá tenía un tono de voz que nunca había escuchado.
Mi mamá habla fuerte.
Me estaba hablando en un tono muy suave, casi apagado,
que transmitía una sensación de tristeza.
En un susurro, me dijo: "Michael,
anoche asesinaron a tu primo Donnell,
en Halloween,
en una fiesta en una casa de Stockton".
Y como demasiados en este país,
especialmente de comunidades como la mía,
especialmente si son parecidos a mí,
pasé la mayoría del año luchando contra el enojo, la rabia, el nihilismo,
y tuve que tomar una decisión.
Tuve que elegir entre la acción y la apatía.
La elección era sobre qué hacer para canalizar este dolor.
Pasé un año lidiando con mis sentimientos de culpa de sobreviviente.
¿De qué me servía estar en Stanford,
para qué me servía estar en la Casa Blanca
si era incapaz de ayudar a mi familia?
Mi familia propia estaba muriéndose, literalmente,
y me empecé a sentir un poco egoísta preguntándome:
¿para qué sirve tratar de hacer que el mundo sea un lugar mejor?
Quizás las cosas son así.
Quizás pudiera sacar provecho de todas las oportunidades que se me han dado
y ganar la mayor cantidad de dinero posible,
para poder estar bien económicamente y que mi familia cercana también lo esté.
Al final de ese año
me di cuenta de que quería hacer algo.
Así que tomé la loca decisión, como lo había hecho en la facultad,
de postularme para el concejo municipal.
Esa fue una decisión improbable por varios motivos,
no solo por mi edad.
Mi familia está lejos de ser una dinastía política.
Más miembros de mi familia fueron a la cárcel que a la universidad.
De hecho, a la hora de dar esta charla, mi padre sigue preso.
Mi mamá me tuvo de adolescente,
y no queríamos mucho al gobierno.
Eso fue porque el gobierno había diseñado
los barrios en los que me crie con muchas tiendas de alcohol
y no de comestibles,
con falta de oportunidades y un foco de pobreza.
Los que decidían sobre la guerra contra la droga
y la condena tras el tercer delito grave
eran el gobierno y los políticos,
quienes encarcelaron a demasiada gente en nuestro país.
El gobierno y los actores políticos
que tomaron las decisiones de cómo dar fondos a las escuelas,
que hicieron que mi escuela recibiera menos dinero por cada alumno
que otras escuelas en zonas más ricas.
No había nada en mi historial personal
que hiciera probable que yo llegara a ser un actor en el gobierno.
A la vez, Stockton era ese lugar improbable para ello.
Stockton es mi ciudad natal y tiene 320 000 habitantes.
Tradicionalmente es un lugar del cual uno se marcha y no al revés.
Es una ciudad sumamente diversa.
35 % son latinos, 35 % blancos,
20 % asiáticos, 10% afroamericanos,
con el templo Sikh más antiguo en EE. UU.
Durante mi candidatura,
fue la ciudad más grande en ese momento
en declararse en bancarrota.
Durante esa campaña
se registraron más asesinatos por cápita que en Chicago.
Cuando decidí postularme
la tasa de pobreza llegaba al 23 %,
el rendimiento escolar al 17 %
y una cantidad de problemas fuera del alcance de alguien de 21.
Después de ganar las elecciones,
hice lo que suelo hacer cuando me siento superado,
me di cuenta de que los problemas de Stockton eran bastante mayores que yo
y que me iba a hacer falta un poco de ayuda divina.
Al prepararme para la primera reunión del concejo,
me acordé de una lección de mi abuela.
Una parábola que creo que conocen
que es parte del marco de gobierno que estamos usando
para reinventar Stockton.
Recuerdo que una vez en la escuela dominical,
mi abuela contó que un hombre le había preguntado a Jesús: ¿Quién es mi vecino?
¿Quién es mi conciudadano?
¿De quién soy responsable?
Y en vez de dar una respuesta concisa, Jesús contestó con una parábola.
Dijo que una vez un hombre
se encontraba yendo rumbo a Jericó.
En ese camino
fue atacado y abandonado en el camino,
desnudo,
le habían robado todo y lo dejaron por muerto.
Un sacerdote que pasaba vio al hombre tirado en el camino,
tal vez dijo una plegaria en silencio,
rezó para que se recuperara.
Quizás lo vio tirado por ahí
y concluyó que Dios habría mandado
que este hombre en particular, de este grupo particular,
estuviera tirado en ese camino, sin poder cambiar nada.
Después del sacerdote, quizás pasó un político.
Como, por ejemplo, un político de 28 años.
Vio a ese hombre por el camino y vio como lo habían golpeado,
vio que era una víctima de violencia, o que se escapaba de una violencia.
Y ese político decidió:
¿Y si en vez de darle la bienvenida, construimos un muro?
Tal vez el político dijo:
"Quizás este hombre eligió estar tirado por el camino".
Si se agarra de los cordones de sus botas,
a pesar de que se los habían robado,
y consigue montarse a su caballo,
podrá tener éxito y no hay nada que yo pueda hacer".
Hasta que, por fin, según mi abuela, pasó un buen samaritano,
y vio al hombre en la calle,
pero lo que vio y observó no fueron siglos de odio
entre judíos y samaritanos,
no vio el reflejo de sus temores,
ni de ansiedad financiera,
no “que me va a pasar con este cambio”.
Lo que vio fue un reflejo de sí mismo.
Vio a su vecino, a su humanidad en común.
No solo vio, sino que también obró,
dijo mi abuela.
Se puso de rodillas,
se aseguró de que el hombre estuviera bien,
y según escuché, hasta le hizo lugar en Fairmont,
el del Pan Pacífico.
(Risas)
Y así me preparé a gobernar,
me di cuenta de que por la diversidad de Stockton,
el primer paso para cambiar era responder la misma pregunta:
Quién es nuestro vecino.
Y de darnos cuenta de que el futuro de nuestra ciudad depende de todos.
Especialmente de esos que quedaron por el camino.
Y me di cuenta de que la caridad no es justicia,
que actos de empatía no son justicia,
que ser un buen vecino es necesario, pero no suficiente,
y que tenía mucho por hacer.
Volviendo a la historia,
me di cuenta de que el camino, Camino de Jericó, tiene un sobrenombre,
lo llaman "el paso de sangre", "la subida roja",
porque ese camino está hecho para la violencia.
Este Camino de Jericó es angosto, perfecto para coartadas.
Quiero decir que el hombre tirado en ese camino no era inusual.
No era algo raro.
De hecho, era algo que estaba planificado para que ocurriera,
tenía que ocurrir.
Johan Galtung, un teórico de la paz,
habla de la violencia estructural en nuestra sociedad.
Dice: "La violencia estructural es un impedimento evitable
de las necesidades humanas básicas".
El Dr. Paul Farmer habla de la violencia estructural
y explica cómo es la manera
de nuestras instituciones, nuestras políticas, nuestra cultura
de crear resultados que favorecen a algunas personas y perjudican a otras.
Y me di cuenta de cómo la sociedad de Stockton, a su modo,
se parecía al camino de Jericó,
que se había estructurado para dar los resultados de los que nos quejamos.
No debiéramos sorprendernos
de ver que a los niños pobres no les fuera bien en la escuela
ni sorprendernos de ver diferencias económicas por raza y por etnia.
No debiéramos sorprendernos de la disparidad salarial entre los géneros,
porque así fue estructurada históricamente nuestra sociedad,
y así es cómo funciona.
(Aplausos)
Y armado de esta sabiduría,
me remangué la camisa y empecé a trabajar.
Quisiera contarles tres historias,
que demuestran que todavía no hemos descubierto todo,
ni que ya estamos ahí,
sino que seguimos el camino correcto.
La primera historia es la de un vecino.
Cuando estaba en la municipalidad,
trabajé con una de las personas más conservadoras de la comunidad
para abrir una clínica sanitaria para personas indocumentadas
en el sur de la ciudad, y me encantaba.
Para abrir la clínica
tuvimos que firmar una resolución,
él me hizo un regalo.
un pin de membresía a "O'Reilly Factor", de por vida.
(Risas)
No le pregunté cómo lo había conseguido,
ni qué tuvo que jurar o hacer para obtenerlo.
Lo miré y dije:
"¿Cómo puede ser que trabajemos juntos para abrir esta clínica
para proporcionar atención sanitaria gratuita a personas indocumentadas,
y tú perteneces al "OReilly Factor?".
Me miró y respondió:
"Concejal Tubbs, lo hago por mis vecinos".
Un muy buen ejemplo de lo que significa
ser un buen vecino, por lo menos en este caso.
Los ladrones.
Así que 4 años más tarde decidí aceptar una candidatura para alcalde,
dándome cuenta de que ser concejal de tiempo parcial no alcanzaba
para lograr los cambios estructurales que Stockton necesitaba,
y llegué a esa conclusión estudiando los datos.
El distrito municipal donde nací,
queda a 10 minutos de uno más rico.
Y a 10 minutos en la misma ciudad,
la diferencia entre los códigos postales 95205 y 95219
es una expectativa de vida de 10 años más.
A 10 minutos de distancia y 7 km,
una diferencia de expectativa de vida de 10 años,
y no por cosas elegidas por las personas.
Nadie elige vivir en una comunidad insegura
en la que no puede hacer ejercicio.
Nadie elige poner más tiendas de venta de alcohol que de comestibles.
Nadie elije eso, pero esa es la realidad.
Como concejal me di cuenta
de que tenía que accionar el cambio estructural que quería ver,
donde en esos mismos códigos postales
hay una diferencia en la tasa de desempleo del 30 %,
una diferencia de salarios de USD 75 000,
que como concejal no iba a poder reducir.
Así que decidí postularme para alcalde.
Como alcalde me concentré en los ladrones y el camino.
Como les conté, en Stockton,
históricamente tenemos problemas por crímenes violentos.
De hecho, eso me hizo decidir a postularme.
Mi primera tarea como alcalde fue ayudar a que la comunidad
se viera como a vecinos,
no solo como a víctimas de la violencia,
sino también como a los responsables.
Nos dimos cuenta de que quienes causan dolor en nuestra sociedad,
aquellos que cometen los asesinatos y contribuyen a la violencia por armas,
suelen ser víctimas ellos también.
Tienen altas tasas de traumas, reciben tiros,
conocen a gente baleada.
Esto no excusa su comportamiento, pero ayuda a entenderlo,
tenemos que ver a estas personas como parte de nuestra comunidad.
Son nuestros vecinos.
Así que, durante estos últimos 3 años,
(Aplausos)
durante los últimos tres años estuve trabajando en dos estrategias:
el cese del fuego y el avance de la paz,
donde le damos a estos tipos tanta atención, afecto,
de servicios sociales, de oportunidades, de borrado de tatuajes,
a veces hasta dinero,
como un regalo para mantener el orden.
El año pasado se vieron 40 % menos homicidios
y una reducción del 30 % en crímenes violentos.
(Aplausos)
Volviendo a lo del camino.
Mencioné que mi comunidad tiene una tasa de pobreza del 23 %.
Proviniendo de la pobreza yo mismo, este es un asunto personal para mí.
Así que decidí que no sería solo un programa,
ni algo muy superficial,
íbamos a cuestionar la estructura propia
de lo que genera la pobreza.
A partir de febrero, lanzamos un proyecto de ingresos básicos
en el que por 18 meses,
a modo de un piloto, se eligieron 130 familias al azar,
de zonas cuyo código postal fuera inferior al de los ingresos medios de la ciudad,
les dimos USD 500 por mes.
Y lo hicimos por un par de motivos.
Lo hicimos porque sabemos
que hay algo que no funciona en la estructura de EE. UU.
cuando uno de cada dos norteamericanos no puede cubrir una emergencia de USD 400.
Lo hicimos porque nos dimos cuenta de que la estructura no funcionaba
si los salarios habían aumentado solo un 6 % desde 1979 a 2013.
cuando había gente que tenía dos o tres trabajos
y que hacía todos los trabajos que no le gustan a nadie,
y no podía pagar cosas esenciales como el alquiler
la luz, los cuidados sanitarios, las guarderías.
(Aplausos)
Así que yo diría que en Stockton tenemos un verdadero problema.
Recibí mensajes de conciudadanos sobre la cuestión de la falta de vivienda,
sobre los delitos violentos que nos tocan.
Yo creo que como sociedad deberíamos retornar
a las historias de la Biblia de cuando éramos pequeños,
y entender que, en primer lugar,
nos tenemos que ver a nosotros mismos como vecinos,
y cuando vemos a alguien diferente,
no deberíamos reflejar nuestros temores, nuestras ansiedades, nuestra inseguridad,
los prejuicios que nos enseñaron, esos sesgos, y, vernos a nosotros mismos.
Deberíamos ver nuestra humanidad común.
Porque creo que cuando lo hagamos,
estaremos haciendo la tarea más importante de restructurar el camino.
Me imagino que algunos de Uds. dirán:
"Alcalde Tubbs, Ud. habla de violencia estructural, y de ese tipo de estructuras,
pero Ud. está en el escenario.
Esas estructuras no pueden ser tan malas si Ud. viene de la pobreza,
si tiene a un padre preso, si ha estudiado en Stanford,
si trabaja en la Casa Blanca y llegó a ser alcalde".
Y yo respondería que eso es algo excepcional.
Quiero decir que es excepcional poder escaparse de esas estructuras.
Según nuestro idioma propio,
sabemos que lo que vemos en el mundo fue diseñado.
Y creo que una de nuestras tareas como TEDores,
y como buena gente que somos, gente justa, gente con principios,
es hacer la dura tarea de no solo unir nuestras manos como vecinos,
sino de usar las manos para reestructurar el camino,
un camino que en este país ha estado lleno de cosas como la supremacía blanca.
Un camino arraigado en misoginia.
Un camino que no funciona para muchos.
Y creo que hoy, mañana, y en 2020 tenemos la posibilidad de cambiarlo.
Así que estando a punto de concluir,
empecé con una historia de hace nueve años y terminaré con otra.
Después del asesinato de mi primo,
tuve la suerte de poder ir a una de las marchas de la libertad
con algunos de los jinetes de la libertad originales.
Aprendí mucho de ellos sobre la restructuración del camino.
Un hombre en particular, Bob Singleton, me hizo esta pregunta
que les haré al concluir.
Yendo a Anniston, Alabama, me dijo: "Michael,"
y le contesté: "Si, señor".
Me dijo: "Me arrestaron el 4 de agosto 1961.
¿Qué tiene de importante ese día?".
Y contesté: "Lo arrestaron,
si no lo hubieran arrestado no estaría en este bus.
Si no estuviera en este bus no tendríamos los derechos que disfrutamos".
Puso los ojos en blanco y replicó: "No, hijo".
"Barack Obama nació ese día".
Y luego dijo que no tenía ni idea que la decisión que tomó
de restructurar el camino
daría lugar
a que un niño nacido como un ciudadano de segunda clase,
que no podía ni pedir agua en el mostrador,
llegara a tener la posibilidad, 50 años después, de llegar a presidente.
Me miró y dijo:
"¿Qué estás dispuesto a hacer hoy
para que dentro de 50 años
un niño recién nacido pueda llegar a ser presidente?
Y yo pienso, TED, que esta es la pregunta con que nos enfrentamos hoy día.
Sabemos que las cosas están empeorando.
Creo que lo que estamos viendo no es fuera de lo común,
sino un reflejo de un sistema estructurado
para producir resultados tan locos.
Y creo que también es una oportunidad.
Porque estas estructuras que heredamos no son actos de Dios
sino de hombres y mujeres, son elecciones políticas,
hechas por políticos como yo, aprobados por votantes como Uds.
Y tenemos una maravillosa oportunidad
de poder hacer algo sobre esto.
Así que mi pregunta es: ¿Qué estamos dispuestos a hacer hoy
para que un niño que nazca hoy, dentro de 50 años,
no nazca en una sociedad arraigada en una supremacía blanca;
no nazca en una sociedad misógina;
no nazca en una sociedad donde la homofobia y la transfobia sean normales
así como el antisemitismo, la islamofobia y el nivel de capacidad de las personas,
y todas las fobias y cosas que terminan en -ismo?
¿Qué estamos dispuestos a hacer hoy,
para que en 50 años
tengamos un camino en nuestra sociedad estructurado para reflejar
lo que nos es autoevidente?
Que todos los hombres, todas las mujeres,
y hasta la gente trans
fueron creados iguales
y que recibieron ciertos derechos inalienables del Creador,
que incluyen la vida, la libertad y la búsqueda de la felicidad.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)